senator Coburn discusses ethics and
accountability in government Senator Tom
Coburn are you glad you came to the
Senate yes sometimes sometimes why well
it's just you know I came to this Senate
because I'm worried about the future of
our country everything that happens in
the short term is kind of noise what we
have to do is look at where we are look
at what's facing us and my only people
ask me all the time if I'm frustrated
I'm not frustrated that we're not making
greater headway because I think we're
awakening the American people to the
problems that are in front of us but I'm
frustrated that we're not attending to
some of those long-term problems that
are in front of us we last talked in
2003 when he wrote a book you were out
of Congress he left in 2001 he came into
the Senate in 2005 here's just a brief
clip from that interview in 2003 can
people really know what's happening in
the Congress today and in the Senate and
they really know all the shenanigans and
they really know that the the pedaling
of influence they got if they really
knew that I think they turn out the
incumbents in a in a moment is that what
happened was some other certainly
happened this last election cycle you
know probably the most important thing
that's happened the last two years is
the the transparency and accountability
act which is going to expose to every
American to how we spend their money and
you're going to be able to follow it
down through subcontractors and
sub-grantees and in the individual
Americans going to know where marks go
and who got the money and who sponsored
him and where all the money goes what
defense contractor you know all the way
down to something we're going to be able
to know that when well the first part of
it starts January of 2008 subcontract
these will be two thousand two thousand
eight nine months later everything will
be online and finished by October of
2008 has that been signed by the
President or today yes sir it has been
signed was our bill
that was my bill
was on it with you barack obama and
several others how'd that happen
Barack and I met when we went through
orientation as freshmen senators and my
wife and his wife struck up a friendship
and Barack and I struck up a friendship
we're polar opposites in terms of our
political beliefs but we both believe
the same thing about we ought to have
efficient accountable transparent
government so what will that do what
will this transparency do for the
average person how can they benefit from
it well it's going to empower those that
are more interested than the average
person to find out the details one
number two they'll be shared whether it
be through the internet or through
newspapers or people who are actually
researching right now I have a staff of
30-some people here and I can't find out
the information it will change behaviors
if people know where the money's going
and how it's going to get there it's
going to caution them to make sure maybe
we're doing this for the right reasons
not the wrong reasons so I think it's
the start to reforming the many steps
we're gonna have to have to get our
government under control why do we need
to do that we need to do that because
we're on an unsustainable course for our
children and our grandchildren you heard
your quote back then when you wrote that
book about Congress near experience
talked about the shenanigans are they
still up to shenanigans in the House and
Senate according to you well I think
yeah I think there's some lack of arm's
length transactions I think there's the
here's a shenanigan you you have a
program and then you got another program
it's doing the same thing rather than
hold this program accountable you create
a new program that's a shenanigan
because not only you're not holding a
group accountable so you don't have to
face the special interests that want
that group you're creating another
you're duplicating the program and you
have tremendous opportunity costs that
are passed on because you're not doing
it the right way because it's hard work
and because you have to confront an
interest group you were term limited by
your own assigned attorney you know
three terms why did you do that
originally because I think we all need
to check on us CS Lewis talked about
this pursuit of the inner ring and how
that's a normal human
behavior unless you step outside of it
and one of the ways to limit your self
aggrandizement and your attaboys to
yourself is to create a perspective of
where you're going and why you came
there in the first place and and I term
limit myself so that I'll keep the focus
on why cane it's not about me and it's
not about me being a senator it's about
me trying to change where we're going as
a country so what have you what do you
plan to do in the Senate well we we've
done a lot no I mean from a turn-on
stance I'm two terms two terms as Matt
and I haven't agreed that I'll run the
second term if I can get a force of
movement going where the American people
are truly involved and they're really
seeing in depth what we're doing and
modified modifying behaviors to extent
where we're starting to think long term
where we're not thinking about the next
election but we're thinking about what's
best for the country and that becomes
the primary emotion then I will consider
my job done when you left here you're in
the majority no longer what's the
difference well in the Senate not much
I'm not a subcommittee chairman any
longer but the rules of the Senate are
such that each senator has a significant
amount of power and the Senate passes so
much without ever debating it without
ever voting on it that all that is
susceptible to being held and I'm one of
those people that put a hold on and I
called the guy that I'm holding the bill
and saying I'm holding your bill and
here's why I don't hide it I'm not
ashamed of the bills I hold and I hope
more bills than anybody do you go to the
Senate dining room occasionally you go
to the Senators private dining room
occasionally how do they treat you fine
there's no animosity about Bob you know
I'm sure with certain senators on
certain times there's these are great
people look I have no problem with the
greatness and the desire of most of the
people that are here but I think we all
fall to the human frailties and what I
try to do is is to put limits on myself
so I can have a check and I have a
wonderful family and a great staff that
is that is aligned with what I'm trying
to do in terms of raising the issue so
the cold that there is occasional
coldness that's okay that's a small
price to pay if in fact we fix the
problems that are in front of us it's
not about me how often do you go back to
my Skokie every weekend with rare
exception and when I'm it's not here
I'll go do something else I've had a
daughter that sang this past weekend in
New York so I went to watch her sing
at the Opera now you you fought both the
House and the Senate over the fact that
you wanted to practice your OB practice
our you know OBGYN arts I'm an old-time
family doctor I've delivered almost
4,000 babies do a lot of other than
primary care but I'm I'm basically your
old-time GP out of the 50s and early 60s
and what's the deal now can you I can't
I can't do anything other than totally
practice for free absorbing all the cost
myself my malpractice my nurses caused
my rent everything else and I've done
that and I've done that
happily to continue to keep my skills
because when I leave here I plan on
continuing to practice medicine you
can't deliver babies unless you deliver
babies so do you do them on Saturday and
Sunday yeah Monday mornings when I have
office have very early Monday morning
office and then I catch a flight and
come back here I do a lot of high-risk
OB
so therefore a lot of mine or repeat
c-sections or inductions for high-risk
people who wouldn't normally make it to
term anyway so you can plan it Oh
60% of it what does it cost you a year
to be able to do this last year of
$49,000 that's everything including your
malpractice insurance for practice in
about 200 hours a year how many babies
you deliver like 27 and why is it the
Senate won't let you take money for this
the well they feel it is a conflict of
interest as a professional for anybody
to pay me money just to cover my cost
their ruling is different than the house
ruling and I won the vote on the floor
but I didn't win with 60 votes to
reverse that and so therefore I'm stuck
with it we may come back but I want to
go back to our interview in 2003 and
just listen to some more what you had to
say to a Robert Byrd who said if the
American public really knew what we were
doing they'd throw us all out
the part of the reason I wrote the book
is I want the American public to see
what's actually happening in Congress
that doesn't have anything they have no
clue about the fact that they write
rules and then break their own rules
that they don't follow what they say on
budgets that they don't do what they
tell the American people that they're
doing and that's leadership on down
anything better than it was then it's
not yet what has to happen in order to
make it better
well I transparency you know awareness a
good example this the continuing
resolution that expires February 15th
it's going to come and you're going to
hear the statement made by the people
that support that Republicans never that
it doesn't spend more money that's an
out-and-out lie because what it does is
it steals money from what we had to fund
troops transitioning back here at home
to for military construction and moves
it to the Supplemental which is off
budget which will spend three to five
billion dollars because of the new CR
that's coming through and use under a
under a supplemental that's doesn't have
to be within the budget guidelines so we
will transfer that three to five billion
dollars directly to our grandchildren so
but you'll say that they'll say we're
within budget and the American public
won't get the game that they're playing
what they'll say there's no earmarks let
me ask you about all this language what
is a CR a CR is a continuing resolution
that we passed at the end of the year to
continue to fund the government at last
year's levels because we couldn't work
through the process of appropriation
bills basically because the power in the
Senate they wouldn't allow us to but
didn't you have something to do with
that continued sure sure I wanted the
continuing resolution rather than have
an omnibus every omnibus I've ever seen
could be an omnibus bill as a bill that
puts it all together and has full of
mischief just like this CR is full of
mischief this continuing resolution
we're going to vote on the 13th of
February does that mean to continue
ative more longer continue to the end of
this fiscal year it's nothing but
another omnibus but they're using the
word continuing resolution and calling
it a continuing resolution any time you
hear the word continuing resolution or
omnibus you should be real worried if
you're an American tax
why because there's all sorts of games
and gimmicks played things that you will
never know about that you have to work
six or seven years back past and other
appropriations bills to find out what
they're doing it's not it's very
sophisticated in the way they write it
so you can't find out what they're doing
but they are you well they are me except
I'm the one challenged in that process
how do you find out about this if you're
inside I take my whole staff and we work
and we work and we work and we work one
bit one one earmark we had to go back 14
years to find out what it was that's
been continuously funded with one
sentence never identifying it over the
past 14 years how much was it I don't
remember them but it you know it comes
to millions of millions of dollars over
14 years why does it have to be this way
it doesn't and that's going to why is it
this way it's that way so that people
won't direct a connection between what
is happening with a certain constituency
or interest group the well-heeled are
very well advantaged under the process
that we have today the well-connected
are very well advantaged under the
process we have today I mean when we
have when we have people earmarking
roads to their own land developments
when we have people doing things for
their own family members yeah I mean and
they want that buried and and that's not
a lot that's a very small minority but
there should be none of that that the
crisis of confidence in our government
the reason we saw the big change there
is no question part of it was the war
but part of it was there's no confidence
that people are really willing to stand
up and do the hard things to make
choices for our country that secure our
future and I I believe we are putting
our future by not addressing both the
culture within the Congress and the
format under which we operate out into
the open and I believe an open
government and a transparent government
will be maybe not quite as efficient but
much more accurate to the needs of this
country and less able and less pliable
to the politicians needs January 19th
2007 New York Times Jonathan Allen
writes the file
the bill s1 what is it I don't know okay
I'll just read the rest it would ban
senators and their staffs from accepting
meals gifts and trips from lobbyists
prohibit senators from negotiating for
private sector jobs while still in
office create a point of order against
bills that do not identify the sponsors
of earmarks establish a database of
lobbyist contacts and activities and
force lobbyists to certify that they
have complied with the gift ban is that
law yet no would it be law not not to
anywhere close to that
I don't believe why not because it's not
in the best interest of the politicians
look the answer to the ethical problems
in the United States Congress is full
disclosure timely and full disclosure if
you can say I can lobbyists can't buy me
a meal to discuss an issue that is a
legitimate issue out in the open and me
put on the website that I had a dinner
with ABC lobbying interest group on this
subject and they can they can't do that
but they can turn around and give $2,000
to my campaign or $5,000 for our PAC to
my campaign and I can have the meal with
them anytime I want as long as I'm doing
in campaign mode you haven't done
anything you've washed the outside of
the cup but the inside of the cup is
still dirty when I can earmark even
though it's out in the open but I might
identify it a little different a hundred
million dollar project for a two
thousand dollar campaign contribution
but I can't have a meal with the same
individual something is very wrong the
answer to ethics in Washington is the
lobbyists are bad people some are just
like some if some of everything is bad
people
the answer is full and complete
disclosure transparency when the
American people get to see what happens
it changes behavior if you know you have
to report it you think twice about
whether or not you're going to do it and
so if it's not ethical it gives you a
pause what this isn't gonna look right
it doesn't pass the smell test if you
get on the FEC the federal action
Commission website today is the last day
that when were recording us on the 31st
we're all your accountability for the
last election has to be
well the elections been over for a long
time and you don't have to file til
today and we probably won't know that
for months as so is that transparency by
the time we find out it's an old old
story well it is but it you know having
done a Senate campaign and very damn we
made mistakes and our FEC filings I mean
that we had were audited and the three
areas that we had we've had corrected
but the point is is the rules are so
complex that you have to file and then
you have to make sure you're right
because there's big penalties if they're
not right I can understand why it takes
that time no but there are rules to have
transparency you know this all ought to
be out there it's just like campaign
finance
if Brian lamb wants to support Tom
Coburn to the US Senate and you want to
give me a certain amount of money as
long as that everybody knows Brian lambs
giving me the money and what your
connection is then I'll have to make a
decision about whether or not how to
take that money and the state of
Virginia has had the fewest number of
ethical problems in campaign of any
state and they have a complete
transparent campaign finance law it's
very good we ought to be modeling that
we ought not be having all these rules
the game that's going to happen if s1
becomes law I will promise you very few
people in the future will run for Senate
or Congress because you every campaign
will be about somebody making a
complaint which will be go to a US
Attorney which will go to a a grand jury
which will be leaked which will be used
as a campaign tool against anybody
that's an incumbent whether it's true or
not it the accusations will be made
so we're destroying because we don't
want to be transparent open and honest
about what we're doing and we want to
set all these rules we're destroying the
desire for anybody in the right mind to
come here and do it why can't a senator
or a member of Congress deal with
outsiders in his office or her office
weekend there's just so much you know I
have to pick from a stack of 70 or 80
people a day to meet with which ones
aren't going to meet with how long do I
keep my staff they're there they're
about 12 hours a day now five six days a
week there are time in advance where you
you know you kind of all work and no
play
makes a guy Doughboy we work all the
time you know this idea that we're gonna
have to work five days a week is an
insult to good working congressmen and
Senators who when they're not here are
working somewhere else I mean they're
not you know when I'm not here and we're
on break I'm not sitting down on my can
I'm traveling the state of Oklahoma
meeting with constituents the whole idea
that if we're not here on a Friday or
Monday that we're not working is
ludicrous let's go back to that 2003
interview it's about the book early on
the book there's a quote from a Trent
Lott who said when he I don't know I
don't have the quote in from me but come
talk to me after the 2000 election then
we'll worry about good government yeah
he said basically I have an election
coming up in 2000 after that we can have
good government that was his quote and
that's not Republican or Democrat that's
career ISM that's saying that the next
election is more important than what's a
good for the health of this country in
the long-term health of this country
Congress has become short term thinkers
it's election cycle thinkers how do I
get reelected and what Congress needs to
be thinking is about our grandchildren
and our children and how do we not how
do we make sure that they have the
opportunities that we've had how do they
make sure that we preserve the freedoms
that we've had and how do we make sure
that the economic opportunities for them
are preserved you name Trent Lott there
or there you named him in my book yeah I
know
and then you named him Bob Byrd and
others again I go back to are you a you
know stay away from Tom Coburn on the
floor of the Senate because he's going
to do is in well my my intention you
know as I told you I think are later in
that interview it's not to say something
about Trent Lott turn lots a very
honorable man he but there's no
difference in him and almost everybody
else up here including me I have those
same tendencies as well Brian I don't
want to let you think that you know I
walk around every day not doing falling
in the same traps I'm human but what we
have to do is guard against that and and
and for the sake of our country we need
somebody talking frankly about what the
competing values are for the people who
are representing us what are those
competing values and have we designed
the system so that we get the best
competition for values to give us the
best result and the best people and I
will
I was one of two people who voted
against that ethics bill because it's
going to tear up the Senate it's going
to tear up the ability for the American
people have great people come and
represent them go over that again now
why will it because if you will be at
such risk to have made an innocent
mistake that you will spend three to
five hundred thousand dollars defending
yourself in terms of an allegation
against you in a court of law not as a
rule this is statute that we passed this
is federal law they said in a Senate
rule this is federal law I if this
becomes law I will guarantee I won't run
again I'm not about to put what I've
worked for for 35 years as a physician
and a businessman at risk so I can
represent the people I will say I'm
cashing it in we've we've just imploded
herself well as you know lobbying is a
huge business in this town yeah and way
bigger than it was ten years ago but the
systematic use of all the little things
to curry favor with the senator the
corporate jets you think that was under
stay I I think whatever if whatever you
put out there if you're transparent if
you're stupid enough to use a corporate
jet on something that is not if for
example I have all the opportunities in
the world go speak all around the
country I can get there so I don't go
speak because I can't use the assistance
of somebody else that might be flying
there and pea we're gonna we're going to
stop the communication you know if I
take a commercial by the time I get to
Dulles by the time I do it you know it's
not worth the effort and and that's not
to defend those that have abused that
practice the problem is us it's not the
lobbyists if you can buy my vote for
right on a corporate jet I don't have
any business being here but it's not
even the buying of your vote as much as
buying of the access well but it's the
same thing if I have no integrity and
the access you know whoever I might ride
with that the access I'm going to give
them in my office anyhow I think they
got a legitimate topic I want to hear
about okay but remember we need both
sides of the issues it's not just that
remember what is thought often is
that you just hear from one lobbyist you
don't you hear from the other side too
so as long as you're balanced in getting
your perception and trying to make a
decision for the best interest long-term
interest not short-term but long-term
interest of the country and you're
you're putting that up here Tom Coburn
flew on X Y Z's corporate jet to here to
give a speech for this here's here's the
topic of discussion when he went there
why was it important for him to give
that speech here's why because he's
trying to change this part of the
culture you know I I wouldn't have any
problem to do that I've not done that
ever and I've done it on some campaign
things but I've never done it an
official business of the US Senate and I
doubt that I ever would but in terms of
campaign events we haven't changed and
you still ride on corporate jet to do a
campaign event well let me ask you about
a practice that is not widespread
necessary I have no idea but the
lobbyist told me of this were he got a
call at midnight from a guy in a
restaurant somewhere says give me your
credit card number lobbyists you know
had he had to make a decision do I say
no to you because he wanted the guy the
lobbyist to pay for his dinner impotency
well we have a rule that covers that
that's a violation the rule what the
lobbyist should have done is reported
yeah Danny I'll never get access to the
guy so what he used after senator do you
want access to that person if you adopt
you an amendment well in the long run do
we really want access to those people if
that's how they operate what we have to
do is have transparency but the public
hasn't got the kind of time you're
talking about to what over indeed it's
not the pose there's plenty of people
that people like Brian lamb they're
gonna look at this and there's plenty of
watching a common cause
OMB watch I mean all these people
there's that's why transparency the
transparency it's just like when you're
a little kid what will you do when your
mom's not there versus what will you do
when she's there there's a big
difference so transparency is that
parental tool that all of us need
including Tom Coburn to make sure we
pause say does this pass the smell test
and that's why I think that's it I think
all of
this ruins what we're trying to do the
the people in the Senate in the Congress
are great people we fall to the
pressures of every everybody else Falls
the same ours are just magnified because
they're in the spotlight but we're not
any different so what we ought to do is
set up a system that helps us in terms
of really but again I'll come back if
you can truly influence me or any other
Center if you can truly influence that
senator with the right they don't need
to be there in the first place you've
elected the wrong person and then that
by by publishing that you're going to
see that influence but you're also going
to caution to that individual that
they're not ever going to do that unless
they think it passes the smell test
why should and unions are twelve of the
top 20 contributors to campaigns instead
of corporation but why should unions and
corporations end up paying really for
you to run they shouldn't look I believe
that people ought to support you if
you're presenting the image that they
think in the long run is but we have to
one of the things our problems are so
big we can't just think about our party
we can't think about our special
interest anymore we better start
thinking about you know the unfunded
liability right now for this country
looking at Medicare Medicare Medicaid
Social Security and all the other
government obligations as far as
pensions and health care is over 70
trillion dollars if you're born today
your portion of that unfunded liability
is four hundred and fifty three thousand
dollars now you tell me how a child born
today can ever get the earning power to
get us out of that mess they can't so we
need to be looking at those problems so
I think you come back and it's who you
put there you know there's no question
I've been called a career politician
because I ran for a Senate after I was a
congressman and did term lines uh and
that's a legitimate criticism but I'll
guarantee is citizen legislators are
much more likely to solve that problem
than career politicians and people who
have never been in the public eye and
people say well they're not qualified
there
qualified because they have a
perspective outside of Washington and
outside of a reelection cycle when you
left here after three terms in the House
you were pretty upset about what you saw
you wrote a book about it and you named
names and all that well what really led
to you running again for the Senate Oh
lots of things I just had come off a
bout of colon cancer and finished Kimmel
therapy and this worst worst personal
decision I could make would be run for
the Senate but I just felt an obligation
you know sometimes you get something
your gut that you think is wrong and and
you're willing to do almost anything to
try to change that and there's a lot of
things I'm wrong about but the one thing
I'm not wrong about is we're a
short-term thinkers not long-term I'm
not wrong that we're putting our kids
and grandkids at risk I'm not wrong and
saying we're in big trouble if we don't
start addressing these right now I came
to the conclusion after a lot of people
came to me that they said you need your
voice there and so I I decided to do it
because I felt it was something I was
supposed to do this isn't a fun job I
mean I don't know anybody who really
thinks this is that great of a job it's
not a fun job it is a tremendously
burdensome job knowing that you can't
change things to fix the future and you
have to work every day to try to do that
if it's not a fun job and you really
like medicine
I just maintain your medical practice
because I would have abandoned what I
thought I was supposed to do look this
country has been tremendous to me I
could have been almost any other place
in the world and not had the
opportunities I went to medical school
as an older man I had a tremendous
business career blessed by a father that
created that opportunity my father was
born in mud hut in Colorado on the
plains of Colorado he left school at 10
and a half years of age I mean where
else can you do that and why should we
not have that for our kids why should
why should we not preserve the heritage
of our country is one of sacrifice why
should we abandon abandoning it is a
sacrifice for me to come here I gladly
give
based on what I've given what I call is
is to Americans that are out there today
who are frustrated with this system come
and serve in the federal government come
make a difference maybe for a short
period I've become we need you we need
fresh ideas not bought into the system
that will help make a change and that's
what I'm trying to build I'm trying to
build an awareness in the American
public of what is happening so that they
I know as they become informed they're
going to demand change and that's part
of what we saw in the last election a
lot has been written about these
earmarks first of all what is it an
earmark to me is something that a
individual senator does that is not
approved by the whole body or is
approved by a committee but benefits a
small interest group at the detriment of
the us as a whole
how does it work though why don't we
know about these a lot of the reasons
that you don't know about them is they
don't want you to know about because
they don't want you to see the
connection between the small interest
group and what you're doing that's not
true on all of them and and 75 or 80
percent of these are great projects
there's no problem with them other than
the fact that it's not out in the open
how we do it and that you're doing it
and that there's a political benefit
that comes to you from doing it more
importantly an earmark and I've kind of
coined the phrase it's a gateway drug to
overspending because if you have an
earmark in a bill regardless how bad the
bill is you're voting for the bill and
if you have an earmark as a state you're
given 49 other states in their market
they may stink so it is a currency of
the politics of staying in power and it
is what is causing us to you you know
the number of lobbyists has increased
the number of earmarks has increased and
the amount of spending is increased in
proportion to all of that so if you
eliminate earmarks and you make people
have to get it tested by their peers in
an authorizing committee if it's truly
authorized and it doesn't and it doesn't
and it passes the smell test then it's
not an earmark but when it doesn't pass
the smell test and it benefits a small
group of people to the detriment of the
vast majority in this country that in
good government let me ask you this and
because we watch as these
new laws are passed that eventually
everybody gets around them some way I
mean you go back to what we're talking
about when it comes to the gift ban that
if you're going to a fundraiser I guess
you can even can you be flown to a
fundraiser yeah if you want to pay for
it as part of your campaign account can
you pay just know it
that has to be you know it has to be
totally contributed to your campaign and
that's within limits so if your fruit if
you're not very frugal with your
campaign money yeah you can but if you
just say anything as a fundraiser you
could have a meal here in this town and
you take Amazon checks and it's a fun
but they have to give you the money they
have to give you the money at the dinner
so you can pay for the dinner I mean
look it's like the balloon you push in
here and it goes out over here
I mean look that's why transparency is
the answer and that's why with
transparency the American people get a C
and it'll change unintended behaviors so
go back to the earmark thing with your
bill on disclosure and transparency will
we know about all those earmarks yes sir
every one of them you'll know who
authored it what it was for who got the
contract who got the sub contracts who
the lobbyist was and what was the vote
when you ended up having it in that in
the Senate unanimous and why was that do
you think because the public pressure
was placed on the Senate to pass this
bill did you have hearings on it
yes we did and we had her markup and
what was the process when you took it in
front of him at hearings and markup
people for it all along yes they went
for it pulling them there but they did
what technique do you use now to out
earmarks challenge them on the floor
when I can find them how often have you
done it hmm I don't know I offered more
amendments to bills than any other
senator last year so but as you hundred
or 60 times it's a get along and go
along town well it is but you know
people are have stomach acid over me I
don't deny that they have they're
probably really good for the drug
companies in terms of senators but the
point is is I am a expected number now
they know
I've just sent a letter or in the
process sent a letter to all of the
Senators that if you want a bill to go
by unanimous consent this year if you're
going to spend new money you have to
offset Oh money you can't create a new
program if it duplicates another program
you have to eliminate the other program
before you expect them to get it passed
by Unanimous Consent by me are you the
only one doing this no I have several
allies but I don't look I don't mind
taking the heat I've already got the
reputation to take the heat so I don't
mind there's no reason for everybody
else to get mad at people that are
helping me when they can be mad at me
and so I don't mind taking that heat the
fact is the American public agrees that
we shouldn't be spending money we don't
have that we ought to be making great
decisions we ought to be prioritizing if
something's over here is not working
well then fix it don't create a new
program and let that one continue to run
what role did you play in the bridge to
nowhere I challenged it on the floor
tried to eliminate it on the floor
transfer the money to New Orleans to
help New Orleans were you the only one
to challenge that bridge well it was my
amendment there were I had 15 people
vote with me it was Senator Stevens
Bridge in Alaska yes he's been around
here for a long time what was his
reaction to you personally I mean
initially angry but look senator Stevens
has done a lot of great things for this
country
I just happened to believe that we can't
keep operating the way we've been
upright if we were in surplus and we
didn't have this problem and everything
was great we were growing at eight or
nine percent per year as an economy we
could afford to not be as frugal with
taxpayers money but I believe that we
ought to well ask the question every
time and so what I'm trying to do is
create the expectation among my peers in
the Senate that if you got something to
done pass the smell test I'm going to be
challenging it and if you really want it
then you got to come to the floor and
debate me on it on why we ought to do it
why does the senator have a unique
amount of power as an individual because
of the rules of the Senate the Senate
rules are set up so that every senator
has an equal say and that we pass most
things by working it all out before we
ever come to the Senate floor and
and that way we can get our work done
and still have the debates over the more
critical issues that need to be debated
in the Senate just based on the rules of
the Senate they know the house may take
something and pass it in a day because
they have a Rules Committee and
closed-off debate and force people to be
quiet in the Senate the tradition and I
think a great tradition is it's the
cooling off it's where things can really
get debated before you conceive more
than one side and so each senator has
the privilege of objecting objecting to
things moving without their input you're
not a lawyer I'm your lawyer
why are you on the Judiciary Committee
because I desire to be there one I asked
for that position number two is I think
sometimes we get caught up in legalese
and we miss some common-sense things and
I think Oklahoma has a great perspective
on thing I think judges ought to be
arbitrators of the country arbiters of
the the Constitution I don't think how
to write any law I think they ought to
protect the innocent as is looked at in
our Constitution I think they shouldn't
be using foreign law to make decisions
about our Constitution and and I want to
have a say and I desire to have a say
and questioning people who are going to
make those decisions so that they don't
expand this balance of power between the
judiciary executive and legislative
branch which I think has been far
expanded too far I think we need a
balance
I don't anytime one of the three
branches gets out of whack it hurts our
country and it's whether you're a
liberal or conservative you can agree
with that if it gets out of back bounce
conservatively it hurts our country if
it gets out of bounds liberally hurts
our country so we need that tension and
our founders were so wise and how they
set it up I want to preserve that bow I
don't want to make it less than what it
should be but I don't want it to be more
than what our founders intended it to be
so that's why I saw what would happen
right now if one of the justices retired
of the Supreme Court less than two years
to go on this president's presidency
well I think I think first of all given
the president's position with not a
majority in the Senate of his party it
would probably change who his nominee
would be I think it would be critical
that we passed I think it would be a big
debate in the country I think those are
great debates for us as
and a half I think the last two Supreme
Court justices were very healthy for our
country and I think that the one thing
you always get is you always get
surprises out of Supreme Court justices
because if they're really thinking
they're not ideologues you know and the
thing that's important about Supreme
Court justice is their judicial
philosophy not their ideology and so
that's why we're all surprised always
from the right or the left at certain
certain positions that Supreme Court
justice but I think it'd be a tough
fight but I think it'd be a healthy one
for our country but you know just for a
moment if John Paul Stevens is 86 87
years old quit he is known as a liberal
judge that would trip the balance there
and especially on an issue that you're
very outspoken on and that's abortion
could you ever get anybody approved well
you may not but the political price to
not do that maybe a change in who's
controls the Senate you know our country
is wonderful this balance that we have
you know it's like this last ASEC
collection time is it less advantageous
for me not to be in the majority sure
but my confidence is in over the 10 or
20 years that are going to come forward
not the two years that are in the short
term in front of me what does America
ride itself and as information that's
why transparency and what we do is so
important because it gives America a
better chance to ride it in a proper
appropriate way so I have tremendous
confidence in our Republic and that
whatever happens that seems to be
negative one from one perspective in the
short term tends to be not so negative
when it's balanced out over time and we
have a we have a wonderful wonderful set
up but it works better when the
electorate is well informed you sound
like you feel might feel better about
things than you did the last time you're
here well we've made a great deal of
change I mean this transparency and
accountability act is a big deal what
what brought that on well is something
that I tried to do in the house and we
brought it on and got it through the got
it through the Senate because there
isn't transparency there's not
transparency at agencies I'm trying to
do not
only you know this is going to cut
across everything why shouldn't you know
how much XYZ contractor at the Pentagon
is making for this subcontract on an on
national security contract
why shouldn't you know why shouldn't you
know who your subcontractors are and
what they're paying
why shouldn't you know that why
shouldn't you know whether this firm in
your in your small town is built in the
government aren't doing a good job for
the government but what makes you think
you're going to learn it this way
because you've got 3,000 people at the
Government Accounting Office
accountability office and they can't
find out a lot of this stuff well that's
because it's mandated and now law that
there has to be put in when it's
legislated and people will have to
comply with it and you will have a
balanced Court challenge when it's not
so that Brian lamb if it's not out there
in clear concise terms you can come and
you can have standing because you're a
taxpayer of this country and you say
we're supposed to get transparency with
this you're not giving us transparency
and the court will enforce that we're
going to get transparency Brian we're
gonna get transparency at every level of
the federal government as long as I'm
still here and I'm gonna work for that
every day because that gives us great
government well what's it gonna look
like for the average person again if
they're gonna be able to hop online and
they're gonna say gosh XYZ got this
grant who's gonna maintain that the GAO
the OMB Office of Management and Budget
isn't it gonna take a lot more people
not a whole lot it was casta down I
think it's eight million dollars set it
up and a couple million dollars a year
running it's not big deal look it's
googling for good government and how how
far will you be able to dig down for the
information
well after September of 2008 you'll be
able to go all the way so you'll be able
to find it there's seven layers of
contractors you're going to get to see
seven layers of contractors if there's
seven layers of grantees you're going to
get to see seven layers of grantees if
it's an earmark you're gonna find out
who got it
you're gonna then you're gonna be able
to say well you got this money in my
commute what'd you do with it in other
words there's gonna be
accountability on the up top side and
there's gonna be accountability on the
bottom side you know just little things
do you say how do you spend your money
they don't know they're the largest
purchaser in the United States of
everything and yet we don't get the best
price tell me why there's not a good
answer they can't give you a good answer
I mean when when the common sense people
start seeing how we operate the
government and what we're doing with it
they're gonna try and change and what
we're planning right now is this
government for your grandchildren how do
you fix it once you start seeing it and
raise the people up that says we want to
changed and then here's the program of
how you change it so how do you
determine whether this is really going
to happen it's gonna happen you know the
person that's responsible for making it
yeah it's it's already being contracted
through em beef to be set up I mean it's
going Rob Portman has assured me we're
watching it clay Johnson at OMB that is
the actual hands-on person that's going
to make sure it happens they're making
it happen and I'm following it what's
the difference just on a day-to-day
basis for you being a United States
Senator versus being in the house
representatives I cover a whole state
have a lot more constituency to worry
about a lot more problems to address a
lot larger staff to try to do that
greater involvement in the process of
everything that goes through our
government because I had can have access
as a senator whereas a House member I
couldn't greater ability to stop bad
things not necessarily a greater ability
to create good things but much more
power to stop bad things what about the
money needed to run how much did it cost
you to run in 2004 I think combined both
myself and my opponent diverse 24
million spent I spent raised and spent
eight million dollars and how did you
raise it part off my reputation as a
House member
a lot of PAC money these very special
interest groups that we also worry about
you know I you know and some of those
people are happy with
what I've done and unhappy with what
I've done but I don't apologize you know
I said I campaigned that my job I'm
going to try to change the culture of
how we operate and so if I run again
we'll have to wait and see but I can
tell you that the confidence I've built
among my constituency of here's what I
said I was going to do in Horizonte is
rising every day now they may be unhappy
with parts of it but there is a
confidence that here's somebody that you
can trust that at least they've kept
their word and so that it's so and I
think that's so important for us is that
we we have to know and verify that what
people say as politicians they're
actually doing and so that's why I like
transparency I think we should be held
accountable and when we're failing then
we ought to be able to have to answer
for it where did you get this interest
gosh I don't know I've never thought
about it I mean you know just
frustration I think in originally where
did you start being frustrated oh I
don't know probably when I was a
businessman and I saw of the things I
tell you one of the things I had a
business south of Richmond Virginia and
I'll never forget the the EEO and
affirmative action stuff came and we
were very progressive we had
african-american supervisors and women's
who provided and I got this form and
said you have to tell us how many
african-americans and how many and I
said we're great at this I'm you know
I'm not gonna report that I mean if I'm
doing the right thing and I'm
accountable and leading in an area
progressive in that area at the time
both with women and with
african-americans why should I have to
spend a bunch of my money in my time
keeping track to prove I'm not doing
something against the government
I think this things have shifted since
the early 60s in our government when
John Kennedy was president I think it
used to be that the for the thought of
the federal government was is we're
going to assume people are going to do
things right
and we're going to catch them if they're
doing them wrong the assumption is now
as you interact with the federal
government you have to prove you're not
a crook you have to prove you're not
doing things wrong not only is that
against the American spirit and
underlying human spirit but it is
tremendously costly and we see all these
layers you know the average small
business now spends six thousand seven
hundred dollars a year per employee on
federal government regulations why what
does that do to produce wealth and
create opportunity and raise the
lower-class up to give them a greater
opportunist
it keeps them down because we're
spending money that doesn't produce
anything when we could be invest in an
education or a new job or a new machine
that makes somebody more productive
which can give them a greater raise I
mean you know that philosophy of where
we've moved to where we're assumed to be
guilty instead of assumed to be innocent
I think is a critical change in how the
government treats the American public do
you have a hero in history or heroes or
people who you admire well I
I probably most admire my father is he
alive No
how long's he been gone 22 years and why
did you why do you admire him the most
just because of his integrity he was a
silent philanthropist silent yeah he
most of what he did nobody ever knew
about he kind of this leadership model
that I try to pattern a lot of what I do
is is a leadership model of serving
others and putting them first and trying
not to think about yourself and trying
to get things done and you know he
modeled that he wasn't he taught me the
work ethic that I have which is
horrendous in terms of work ethic but he
he was still somewhat balanced in how
what did he what was he working to
achieve he was working to achieve
something for other people what'd he do
he he created and built the business and
manufacturing ophthalmic machines and
eyeglasses the very thing that you
weren't on your face he developed most
of the technology that allows us to
grind or polisher or injection mold
contact lenses and I were were their
brothers and sisters on your family how
many two brothers and sister one is
deceased older younger older where'd you
meet your wife second grade when did you
marry her as a junior in college at
Oklahoma State uh-huh he went to
University of Oklahoma med school I went
to Oklahoma Mexico three daughters three
daughters where are they
ones in Irvine California with her
husband ones in Muskogee Oklahoma with
her husband she has four children and
ones in New York City what do they think
of what you do well they're apprehensive
at first there each time I've taken off
into the the political call weeds but I
they're very supportive what do you see
sitting inside the 100 United States
senators institution
as we go through these next couple years
when everybody's running for president
has it changed if you sense that there's
a change because everybody's running
oh sure you see the superficial change
that people do to position themselves
and and try to you know to get a step up
the stair and I don't begrudge them that
at all I think that is normal human
behavior and and I don't see anything
wrong with that because that's the way
we elect presidents I mean you know as
you got a yet have to create a name for
yourself you have to try to raise your
fundraising you have to try to get
endorsement you have to try to do all
these things but I don't think it's it
structurally will change the general
direction of the Senate will you get
anything done over the next couple of
years well yeah I think I think there's
greater I think that this idea of a
divided government in a bad idea
I think I think it causes it forces
compromise and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I think the
Republicans could have done much more
and been greater stewards of the
public's money had they had a good sharp
veto and President Bush's hands you know
that it's it's kind of like we we don't
want to have the debates and we don't
want to you know do the hard work we
just want to kiss and make up and pass
it and force it through and debating in
our country the very issues that are
important to us are very important for
our country because even if you lose a
debate if I'm on the floor and I lose a
debate with a vote
I have advanced my position to at least
people get to see what that position is
when you when you do everything by not
debating it by not having markups by
doing a by unanimous consent the
American people lose because they don't
get to see what's really going on and I
would love to see the Senate you know
the Senate spends half a time have its
time in a quorum call
I would love to see us change the rules
where we can run two or three things at
the same time have ongoing debates and
and really have debates before we here's
this side of the argument here's this
side of the argument American people
make it we don't get to see that very
often that's what I want to try to
create and that's why I'm down there I
I'm down there challenging the
as quo on some of the earmarks I'm
challenging the status quo whether we're
going to move bills without debating and
whether we're going to vote not getting
a recorded vote you know it's I tried to
have a recorded vote on this last ethics
bill this s one you talked about the pre
would preclude a senator from enhancing
a spouse or a staff member or their
staff members family with an earmark I
couldn't get an agreement to have a vote
on that let alone the debate they didn't
want to debate that and they didn't want
to get on record as voting for that why
not there's there's not a good answer
for why not other than you intend to
allow that to continue to happen have
you given any thought to running for
president no sir I've given a lot of
thought first of all my I don't have the
capability to do that job one number two
it's not something I'm called to do I'm
in a great position to be a voice for
change and to enable somebody who has
those skills hopefully to come in and
take advantage of that voice for change
and fix our country last time here we
talked about two cancers a melanoma when
you were young in their 20s and colon
cancer a couple years ago any residual
hope not looking pretty good right now
got great doctors that taken care of me
great drugs and why do you think we have
great drugs and great doctors what's the
source of that well I
we're losing the great doctors fewer and
fewer qualified people are going into
medicine and we're about to lose the
great drugs because we're going to take
away the incentive for research because
we had because we're gonna try to if you
look at what happened to the vaccine
industry as soon as the federal
government became the number one
purchaser in the vaccine the vaccine
industry we went from something like 39
manufacturers to six and as soon as we
had 9/11 we had nobody produced most of
the vaccines that we need to protect
ourselves from weapons of mass
destruction in terms of biological we
lent we decimated the industry we made
it an on investment non research
oriented industry we made it a commodity
industry and that's what's happened in
most of the other countries who have not
had a vibrant drug industry now
is there criticism to be the drug
industry sure do we want to take and let
the government to be the number one
provider that say here's what you'll pay
for it that's what the rest of the world
does to us that's why Americans are
subsidizing all the research in the
world for drugs and that's why we pay
higher but the answer is not to destroy
the golden cow the answer is to have the
foreign policy to those that don't allow
our drug companies to have open markets
in their their country there ought to
pay a price if Germany doesn't want to
allow a pharmaceutical country company
in this country to have an open and fair
competition for its product then maybe
they shouldn't have an open fair
competition for their automobiles here I
mean we we have not seen the strength at
the administrative level on trade issues
where we are unfairly treat treated like
the pharmaceutical industry is it is
tremendously and so we have as a
consequence Americans are paying much
more for their drugs than what they
should and consequently we will continue
to do so unless we fix the real problem
Washington's oftentimes about fixing the
symptoms and not the problem it's great
analogy for medicine if you come to see
me and you have pneumonia and I treat
your cough and your fever but never
treat your pneumonia your bacterial
pneumonia with an antibiotic you look
okay for three or four days and then
you're gonna get sicker than all get-out
because I treated your symptoms that's
too often what we do here we are
treating symptoms and not the real
underlying disease the underlying
disease the symptom is high drug prices
the underlying disease is we don't have
a true global market for pharmaceuticals
let's treat that the prices of our
markets work if we have real markets
what we have to do is make sure we have
the real markets how big an issue well
health care be you think in 2008
election I think it'll be gigantic
gigantic and we're I'm getting ready to
introduce a global health care bill not
thinking that my bill will pass but to
create the the start the real debate the
President did some of it this is this is
a big bill it emphasizes prevention the
only way we get out of that 70 trillion
dollars is to start investing in
prevention 50% of the diabetes in this
country is preventable
let's incentivize the prevention heart
disease we can we can make it to where
you don't die from heart disease early
through prevention colon cancer half of
it can be prevented or at least prevent
it from becoming cancer I mean all these
things we've we have a we have a health
care system that's based on treatment of
chronic disease rather than prevention
of disease and we need to shift our
dollars to prevention I'm talking the
federal government we've spent seven
eight billion dollars a year and twenty
six different agencies and we get
nothing for it we're out of time
all right thank you senator Coburn
enjoyed speakership
[Music]
poor copy on DVD or VHS tape call one
eight seven seven six six two seven
seven two six four free transcripts or
to give us your comments about this
program visit us at QA or QA programs
are also available as c-span podcasts
[Music]